das ist so ein richtiger bmx helm also
das ist kein helm der scheiße aussieht
das ist wirklich ein helm der mit dem
man schon auch gut wegkommen zu hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
das wäre ja ich hoffe natürlich geht es
allen gut heute jetzt wirklich ernst ist
also man muss sagen die letzten videos
haben sich immer gesteigert es wird
immer krasser und immer krasser und
heute wird es noch besser war als ich
die 200 euro
saturn überraschungs wundertüte
ausgepackt habe habe ich gesagt wenn
dieses video an diesem abend noch 6000
geschafft bestelle ich direkt die für
800 die 6000 likes wurden ziemlich
schnell erreicht und dann wollte die
bestellen es gab allerdings zu dem
zeitpunkt nur wieder die für 500 das ist
voll komisch jetzt gerade gibt es gar
keine mehr
außer von einem andern saturn weswegen
ich denn jetzt erstmal die für 500
bestellt habe ich hoffe das ist okay das
ist ja auch noch mal eine krasse
steigerung die ist heute angekommen was
ich nur sehr komisch finde ich zeig euch
mal entschuldigung 500 euro also 1500
euro warenwert soll hier drin sein
ich hab mir die viel größer vorgestellt
weil die zwei euro box war zum beispiel
größer als die hier oder ungefähr gleich
nicht eigentlich bisschen größer
deswegen müssen hier kleinere sachen
drin sein die aber viel mehr wert sind
wie zum beispiel ein handy oder so ihr
könnt ihr ja täglichen handy drin sein
ich meinen 1500 euro das muss man ja
irgendwie volk religion gerade gesagt
ich schaue noch mal nach aber es gibt
absolut keine boxmeer vom saturn
dortmund die ich bestellen kann also die
sind alle weg ihr könnt ihr sehen da
kommt gar nichts mehr
ich hoffe allerdings dass wird wieder
aufgestockt das waren im letzten mal
auch so
und nächste woche kann man dann
eventuell wieder raus bestellen wir
machen jetzt erstmal auf
was mir noch aufgefallen ist eine sache
gekommen diesmal nicht vom saturn
dortmund sondern von saturn witten
obwohl ich bei saturn dortmund auf ebay
wirklich keiner anhalt hatte muss man
irgendwie auch mal durchsteigen geld
kann man nicht durch stein ist mir auch
egal woher das kommen solange der inhalt
gut dann machen wir das mal auf ich
musste mich gerade wieder so ein
normales küchenmesser besorgen weil ich
noch kein anderes hab okay was man aber
schon sagen muss die ist diesmal auf
jeden fall deutlich besser verpackt als
die letzte
ok ich hab' schon eine sache gesehen
kein fan was das ist und die tür ist
doch auch diesmal mache ich das ganze
hier alleine deswegen nicht die box
jetzt einfach mal hier so stehen lassen
das aber alles mal öffne ich bin schon
etwas nervös ich habe heute auch schon
viel kaffee getrunken aber ich hoffe es
wird geil es muss gäbe
die letzte war ja schon nicht so neid
ganz viel folie was ist das denn es sind
nicht viele sachen drin
heute ist also es sind große sachen aber
nicht viele letztes marken wir bestimmt
fünfzehn zwanzig verschiedene sachen ich
fand einfach mal hier mit an und will
das raus
oh mein gott ein live-ticker und einfach
ich würde es ist kein fett es ist kalt
es ist kein feld nicht bevor das
natürlich regel dadurch werde wenn ich
da jetzt wieder fake lesealter ich
dachte mich rasch und so auf den ersten
blick
das sind nur drei sachen drin wie sollen
das 1100 euro wert sein egal
wir starten hier erstmal mit dem mit dem
wifi abi kann ich nicht viel mit
anfangen
leider ich habe schon mein telekom
magenta smartphone das ist hier überall
schon integriert aber so schlimm ist es
gar nicht weil vielleicht könnt ihr
jemand falsch
vielleicht könnt ihr jemand von euch was
damit anfangen
wtf also wir haben hier gute ich kann
das jetzt nicht genau zuordnen ich tippe
mal es ist jetzt weiß ich was das ist
ich dachte dass wir wer seine smart home
base dass man hier halt auch smartphone
produkte mit stellen kann nein ist es
nicht das sind so ein verstärker die
kannst du in deinem ganzen haus
aufstellen dann hast du halt überall
starkes weder wenn man ein großes haus
hat wie ich hier zum beispiel ist nicht
habe kann man das auch nicht verwenden
soweit ich habe überall gutes internet
ich habe hier eine eine million leitung
also ohne scheiß ist es sehr schnell das
internet ihre das bin ich auch sehr froh
darüber
deswegen packe ich das auf jeden fall
mal zu den sachen die im dezember alle
rausgehauen werden dazu wollte ich auch
noch mal eben was sagen und zwar habe
ich beim letzten video ultra oft gelesen
alex du bist voll undankbar und von
abgehoben und so du machst die ganzen
sachen voll runter nur weil du das nicht
brauchst heißt es nicht dass die anderen
menschen das sich brauchen uns so und
dafür muss ich mich glaube ich ein
bisschen entschuldigend wobei ich bei
manchen sachen vielleicht ja ich hab das
unglücklich ausgedrückt das akzeptiere
ich auch so verstehe ich auch voll
speziell jetzt das navigationssystem wo
ich meinte er
was heutzutage doch ich habe halt
gedacht so auch die jugendlichen 18 19
jährigen wenn man jetzt noch kein geiles
auto hat irgend einen alten golf oder so
man benutzt auch mal sein handy oder und
ja also ich könnte mir den meisten
sachen da halt leider nichts anfangen
und tut es mir leid wenn das halt
irgendwie manchmal blöd rüberkommt das
war auf jeden fall nicht so gemeint also
ich bin ein sehr dankbarer mensch und
ich weiß das ist alles nicht
selbstverständlich ist und so toll ok
weiter geht's also ich muss sagen ich
hatte in dem ding sind nur vier sachen
drin mehr nicht aber es sind halt
wahrscheinlich alles sachen mit protect
your kid 5 in einem ach so aha das gibt
es das gibt es weiter tun ja für die
sicherheit muss gesorgt sein
wir machen das mal aus ich glaube das
sind so sachen wie helm jungen 14
fahrrad hellen drinnen ja für die
sicherheit
finde ich nicht schlecht wir haben
einmal im coolen helm
das ist so ein richtiger bmx helm also
das ist kein helm der scheiße aussieht
das ist wirklich ein helm der mit dem
man schon auch cool wegkommen zu oder ja
und dann natürlich hier auch noch ganz
wichtig die warnweste damit man auf
gerade jetzt bei der jahreszeit wenn es
draußen dunkel ist erkannt wird von den
autofahrern
so das sieht doch an sich frisches oder
und dann haben wir hier noch schon ab
also alles was man so braucht um sich
halt sicher im straßenverkehr bewegen zu
können finde ich auch sehr cool brauche
ich selber nicht also ich war zwar gerne
fahrrad aber irgendwie ja eigentlich ist
es besser ein helm zu tragen
das ist wirklich besser aber ich würde
es auch zu den sachen legen die ich dann
im dezember verlosen
und ja ich hoffe da kann jemand mehr mit
anfang als ich selber das ist auch gute
ware wird von eicken bit ist kenne ich
nicht aber ihr vielleicht dann stellen
wir das aber mal hier rüber und kommen
jetzt zum nächsten produkt ich habe das
auch ich habe ja alles jetzt schon
gesehen ich zeige euch das jetzt erst
mal sorry wir haben hier tatsächlich das
ist einmal das ist dumm
es ist wirklich also das ist wirklich so
ein krasser fall hätte ich erkläre ich
jetzt gleich mal wieso wir haben hier
eine kovacs saugroboter das ist der
titel im 2 ich habe keine ahnung
der ist wahrscheinlich schon ein
bisschen älter
wir checken das einfach mal kurz meine
haare sind jetzt wahrscheinlich voll
es geht noch wegen dem helmrath egal ich
habe ja ein
so die botti slim 26 monate
den gibt es gar nicht mehr also das ist
schon etwas älteres modell kostet jetzt
noch 200 euro im internet so ungefähr
trotzdem muss ich sagen ich habe eine
kooperation mit eco taxi sind super cool
immer und ich habe euch ja auch schon
einiges saugroboter vorgestellt und ich
habe vor nach stunde eine mail an die
verfasst dass ich im dezember wieder so
ein give away und so was alles mache ob
ihr nicht doch hätten mir ein paar
geräte zur verfügung zu stellen sage ich
euch jetzt so wie es ist ich mein an
sich ist es nur in situation für alle so
ich werde aber natürlich auch selber
weitere sachen kaufen von meinem eigenen
geld coole sachen die ich dann auch noch
heraus habe versprochen deswegen ist das
geradezu verrückt dass ich hier jetzt
einfach so ein ding habe ich habe meinen
eigenen songs roboter ich habe ihn
gerade immer seit drei wochen und ich
bin sehr zufrieden
deswegen kann ich den ja auch nicht
gebrauchen und legten auch zu den sachen
die dann im dezember halt raus gehen und
jetzt können wir tatsächlich dann schon
zum nächsten produkt ich muss sagen ich
weiß noch nicht welches iphone das ist
es ist auf jeden fall irgendein iphone
unterwegs also das sieht anders aus
leute seid ihr bereit ich schwöre ich
habe das nicht gefällt dabei ist
wirklich der iphone drin das kann man
aber auch erwarten oder dann vielleicht
für den preis so ich hätte eigentlich
mit noch mehr produkten gerecht
128 gb iphone 8 das ist doch gar nicht
so verkehrt das ist schon da bin ich
jetzt schon zufrieden mit ich meine ich
habe 500 euro wir agieren dass jetzt
gleich mal kostet nicht im iphone 8 wenn
man es neu kauft auch noch 4 500 euro
mit 128 muss das gleich mal alles
agieren
ich glaube nicht dass wir auf diese 1500
euro
aber wer weiß ich mache das einmal auch
so ich gehe da nicht dran
ich habe ja mein handy aber um es einmal
zu zeigen dann ist das gute schon mal
also das ist doch wirklich schon mal ein
produkt wie man sich richtig darüber
freut gerade wenn man neues handy
brauche oder so wir haben uns schön
iphone 8 128 gb nice alter kopfhörer
dabei ja gut muss also dabei ist in weiß
oder space ja doch feiere ich mega mit
uns nur ein bisschen leid ich hätte
gedacht das video wird wieder viel
länger weil viel mehr sachen kommen
diesmal waren halt einfach viel teurere
sachen drin trotzdem ich weiß noch wie
ich vor zwei jahren 2018 auf so ein
gewinnspiel gemacht habe und der
hauptgewinn war auch ein iphone 8 das
habe ich damals selber gekauft kann ich
zwei jahre später noch mal raus haben
ich muss mich korrigieren farbe silber
gerechnet dass jetzt alles mal zusammen
ich nehme natürlich jetzt den neupreis
ich habe hier einst bei amazon für 348
euro 55 das würde ich jetzt einfach mal
so ein geben
fangen wir damit nur an 348 euro 55
hatte eigentlich gedacht ist es noch
teurer + den ex saugroboter den habe ich
für 195 euro im internet gesehen dann
sind wir schon mal bei 543 euro
also irgendwie komme ich überhaupt nicht
ob ich hätte die hätten ruhig noch mehr
rein tun können egal wir haben da noch
diese orbi mai file station die jetzt
aber eigentlich auch nicht so teuer sein
kann oder ok wieso ist das so teuer
alter 350 euro ihr sogar 600 warte mal
kurz welche ist das genau ich dachte das
kostet der zuwachs war ein huhn okay
jetzt habe ich es gefunden alter wir
haben ok jetzt geht's wir haben hier den
rbk 23 das neueste system von den kostet
einfach 1038 euro
das habe ich jetzt gefunden für 340 euro
dann nehmen wir das einfach mal dazu 340
euro also das ist auch schon nicht
schlecht plus 340 euro sind wir mal 883
euro jetzt fehlt noch dieses protection
kit irgendwie findet man das kaum im
internet ich glaube das müsste schon ein
bisschen älter sein
bei amazon ist das angegeben mit
zwischen 16 euro und 60 euro 20
nehmen wir einfach mal die mitte sage
ich mal plus 40 euro sind bei insgesamt
bei 923 euro 55 kosten die sachen zu
sagen
die box ist leer ist nichts mehr drin
also habe ich jetzt hier ein gewinn von
423 euro 55 was natürlich nicht schlecht
ist aber ich hätte halt gedacht wir
kommen auf 1500 euro warenwert weil es
auch damit angegeben war vielleicht wird
das dann so berechnet dass die 1500 euro
der wert ist den die mal insgesamt
damals für die ganzen sachen bezahlt
haben soll ein iphone hat ja auch mal 7
800 euro
ein paar ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lasse mir doch nach oben da wenn ich
noch eine teure box bestellen soll 1000
euro wir halt schon krass das war es von
mir wir sehen uns die tage wieder
abonniert den kanal in dem zimmer wie
das alles raus kommen an die abonnenten
haut rein